SACHIT EGAN: Hello everyone.
Welcome to Talks at Google.
My name is Sachit Egan.
Thanks for being out here today.
I'm really excited about the
hour we have ahead of us.
And it's my privilege today
to introduce Karan Bajaj.
Karan has been the
Chief Marketing Officer
at Aden & Anais in New York.
He's also worked as a director
for Kraft Foods, a brand
manager for Procter and Gamble,
and is a management consultant
for Boston Consulting Group
in India, the Philippines,
Singapore, and here in the US.
In 2007, he was named a top
40 under 40 marketer in the US
by "Advertising Age."
And he was selected as one
of the top 10 young business
leaders in India by the
Aditya Birla Foundation.
Karan has authored three
novels-- "Keep Off the Grass"
in 2008, which was a
semifinalist for the Amazon
Breakthrough Novel Award,
"Johnny Gone Down" in 2010,
and "The Seeker,"
which was published
in India this past year.
And "The Seeker" has now
just been published in the US
this past month as "the
Yoga of Max's Discontent."
And also worth
noting that Karan is
going to take over as CEO of
a major media company in India
later this year.
Before I invite Karan
up, I'd be really remiss
if I didn't say I've been really
fortunate with Talks at Google
to read a lot of books, many
of them "New York Times"
bestsellers, number
one bestsellers.
But the "Yoga of Max's
Discontent," far and away
the best one that I've read.
So we've got it for sale here.
I highly encourage
you to check it out.
Karan will talk for
about 15 minutes.
Then I'll do some Q&A with him.
And then we'll take
questions from the audience.
Without further ado, please help
me welcome Karan to the stage.
KARAN BAJAJ: Thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you, Sachit.
Thank you for having me.
Does he say that for
every talk, by the way,
like it's the best book
I've ever read in my life?
I'm delighted to be here.
So I'll speak for a few minutes
before we go into the Q&A.
So I wanted to start
with a question.
How many of you
have ever fantasized
about leaving it all
behind-- your job,
your career, everybody?
So my goal really in
the next 20 minutes
is to convince you
to do it today.
So bear with me as
I speak to this.
I'm going to talk a
little bit about what
I've been doing over
the last decade, which
is what I call a four, one, four
model in which I work for four
years, take a year off,
then work for four years,
take a year off.
I'm going to talk
about why I do it,
and then perhaps why it might
be an interesting idea for you
to consider.
So that was the
purpose of this talk.
And this idea came to me
like about a decade ago
when I was thinking that
me, like many people,
wanted my life to be like this.
I wanted every career move
that I made, every job location
I changed, from
India to Philippines,
I wanted everything
to just work out.
I wanted everything to
be successful and right.
And I wanted my life to be
one linear line of growth
and progression.
That's what I realized
that I wanted.
But then you look at
successful people--
and many of you in this
room are successful-- you
see that this is what successful
people's lives look like.
They do some great things, then
they stumble badly, like Steve
Jobs or whoever you think of.
Then they pick up the pieces
again and then do something
again, then this jumble again.
And then they reach kind of
like a height of greatness
that the linear line
never reaches you to.
So obviously we all know
failure is important.
It makes you humble again.
It makes you a beginner.
It makes you try out new
things and expand your horizons
and all that stuff.
And I was wondering, how
do I almost build failure
into my life rather than
waiting for external events
to make me feel almost-- so
I was almost thinking on,
is there a way to build
this into your life,
this idea of being
a beginner again,
this deconstructing completely,
losing your sense of I
know anything at all, and
feeling that kind of bottom--
hit the bottom almost willfully.
So I started this idea, and it
didn't start like this four,
one, four perfect system.
But I was like
every few years, I'm
going to leave
everything behind.
I'm going to leave my job.
I'm going to leave
my comfortable house.
I'm going to leave everything
behind and be a beginner once
again.
So I started to
play with this idea.
And about, I think, 12 years
ago I took my first sabbatical,
in which I did exactly that
with these three principles
that have actually
surprisingly not changed all
that much in all these years.
The content of the
sabbaticals have changed,
but the principles
haven't changed.
My first idea was that I
want to be a beginner, so
let me learn something that
is completely new for me
and feel the humility of
being a beginner again.
And that was kind of
the first principle.
The second idea was that I
want to be physically very
uncomfortable, because what I
was noticing with my life is
that the moment you reach
a basic level of comfort--
I guess you have a house, a job.
You start adding layers
and layers on top of it.
You know, you're like, I
want to be in this school
district for my kids.
I'm a vegetarian.
I love organic food.
I have to have green juices.
There has to be a
Whole Foods next to me.
You start adding all these
layers into your life.
And I wanted to break
that construct completely
and ask myself, what do
I really need to survive.
And so the idea that
I was playing with
is, how do I become
completely poor again almost,
and see what it takes.
So for example in
the last sabbatical,
my wife and I spent six months
in an ashram in the Himalayas
living on the
floor of the ashram
and taking cold
showers every day.
And it's very liberating.
I was playing with this idea
and I found again and again
that it's very liberating,
that when you do that,
you come back with
a very heightened
sense of perspective
about what matters
and what doesn't matter.
And you make very authentic
choices to yourself.
And we'll talk a little
bit more about it.
But that was the other idea.
And then the third
idea was that we all
have this impulse to create.
And that's what makes us leave
companies and open our startups
and all that stuff.
And I wanted to, again,
feel that impulse to create,
but without any goals associated
with that creation at all.
So I didn't want to-- I
wanted to play with things
without having this idea
that I have to get VC funding
or make it successful.
I wanted to be
consciously goalless
and just feel creation
in its purest form.
And so that's why
this idea was that I
would take a year off
and come back again, so
that I have no goals
tied with this creation
apart from just feeling it.
So I've done three of these
over the period of the last 12
years.
And they've ended up
being four, one, four.
I wasn't that mathematical
at the beginning,
but it ended up being this
every three, four years,
I have this feeling that my
life has too many attachments.
I'm weighed down by
my views about things.
I'm forming a very
solid sense of myself,
and let me break
that down completely
and become zero again.
So over the last decade,
this is what's happened.
I started with the usual stuff.
I quit my job at Procter
& Gamble that time
and started traveling.
And I went backpacking
and the usual stuff.
Basically I lived in places
that I'd always fantasized about
like Bhutan and Mongolia,
for no apparent reason,
but I just should do it.
And then I started to write.
And this is funny because
till 27 years of my life,
I had probably not written
a single creative word.
And at 28, I started
writing a novel.
And kind of like
it just happened,
and then I wrote a
novel which actually
did pretty well in India.
And things started to change.
And then that kind of
planted this idea to me
that you just don't
even know what you're
capable of until you kind of
break down the structures that
surround you, because I'd never
even knew that I could even
write a novel.
Like I had no impulse
as a kid to write.
But I had the space
that opened up.
I realized that I was feeling
a little empty while traveling,
because I just
didn't want to see
the 15th cathedral in Germany.
Like I just didn't have any--
and that opened up the space.
I started to write.
It became something.
And then I started
see that I was
getting even attached
to this idea of writing.
And every sabbatical
I would write a novel.
So I kind of broke that
down in the last sabbatical.
I even broke this idea that I
had to write anything at all.
For the first nine
months of this 12 months,
I was just drifting.
And I became a yoga teacher,
a meditation teacher,
or learned yoga and
meditation rather.
And in the last
two or three months
I wrote this novel, which
I completed once I actually
came back.
Like every time I
do that, I learn
things in completely new space.
Like I learned writing.
I learned yoga.
I learned meditation, in
very, very great depth.
The funny part that I
wanted to talk about though
was something else, which
is through all of this time,
I felt that my career would
really derail completely,
because I was like, who wants
this guy who they can't trust
because he works for four years
and then he disappears and goes
to the Himalayas.
And I thought my career
would either derail
or at best I'd be
like, please give me
a job back sort of a thing.
But the funny phenomenon
that I started
to notice-- with
all my humility I
guess-- but the funny
phenomenon I started to notice
was that my career was actually
quite stable before that.
I was working for
Procter & Gamble
and I was doing reasonably well.
And suddenly when I started
doing these sabbaticals,
I came back and
just accelerated.
The first time it
happened, I thought
it was very lucky,
like I had not
paid the dues of
taking this time off.
And then the next time I
did it, I came back again
and I saw that my promotions
were happening faster than I
ever was being promoted before.
I was just on this
very accelerated
curve again and again.
So at P&G, I was like a
manager, assistant manager.
And then suddenly I
came back, joined BCG,
got promoted quickly,
became director, then
became chief marketing officer.
Now I'm taking on the
CEO kind of thing.
Every time I've come back
from these sabbaticals--
so I started in the
last few as kind
of starting to reflect on why
this is happening, which is I
think the reason I wanted
to talk to you guys
about because you guys are
all-- obviously you're here
in this prestigious place.
You're very ambitious
and career focused.
And this is not like
the hippie track.
I almost feel it's a brilliant
thing that can actually
transform every
part of your life.
Not just the new skills that
you're learning as a writer,
as a yoga teacher,
but it actually
impacts your career in the
most positive way possible.
And I have some hypothesis
on why that has happened,
which could be
interesting-- and these
are just hypothesis
right now-- is
that the first hypothesis
that you actually
deepen a lot as a person.
For example, taking
just one activity
of the sabbatical, when I
think of writing novels,
every time I write one
book, it completely
draws into the well
of everything I know.
And I put all of
that into a book,
and I'm completely dry
and empty after that.
And then my natural impulse
is to fill that well
with a whole breadth of
new experiences again.
And if I had never done that
creative activity of writing
a book or something like that,
I would never have had the,
I guess, impulse
to try a hundred
different new experiences in
order to fill the well again.
And again and again I'm seeing
that with this kind of model,
when you're doing an
activity which is completely
different from your
work and you're
putting all your kind of
creative energy into it,
you need to replenish it.
And that gives your life
a natural kind of depth
because you are always seeking
growth, seeking experiences,
and it becomes a very
important part of your life.
And then what starts to happen
is that over a period of time,
all these dots start to connect,
because obviously learning
yoga and meditation does have
an effect on your personality.
And that shows up in work.
And then even small things like
if I'm marketing my novel, what
I learned from that helped.
Like you see like life is
just one interconnected stream
in which you are
kind of learning
in very, very different
dimensions all the time.
So that's one kind
of idea that happens.
The second idea, there is
this beautiful human concept
of dharma which means that
everything has a natural trust.
Like the trust of the trees
to grow and bear fruit,
it's not to flow like a river.
That's the thrust of the tree.
And every human has a certain
thrust, a certain tendency.
And what happens is
that our-- call it
that gut or the tendency gets
enveloped with a lot of-- greed
is not the right word, but
it gets a little bit greed
in the sense that you start
to put too many layers on what
you need.
And that's where you're
like, I can't do this
because I need this
for my kids' education,
my kids' college fund.
You start putting all
these layers around you.
With all of these
sabbaticals, what happens
is then when you're
pushing yourself
to physical discomfort, if
you spend nine months sleeping
on the floor of an ashram,
guess what, when you come back,
you're not like, what's the best
school district and the best
house that I can buy.
You're like, oh, I can
survive with nothing,
so let me just come back
and do what's right.
And I felt that my
choices have become
extremely authentic,
and very true to what
I want to do based on again
and again reminding myself
that I need.
My wife and I need very
little to go back on.
That's the other thing
that I've started
to see has led to much more
authentic decision making.
And then the final
thing is this whole idea
that you become very intuitive.
Like for me, I'm an
engineer, business school,
very left brained.
My whole way of operating
things is analysis and models
and thinking.
And when you're on this kind of
a completely surrendered year.
And so we'll talk a little
bit about going from Europe
to India by road
without any plan at all.
You just learn to become
very intuitive about how
you make decisions.
And I've seen again and
again once I come back,
my decision making have left
that rational part of me
behind.
Or like I'd be very
comfortable making
very big strategic
decisions on work
based on just what
my heart is saying.
And I'm not that kind
of person at all.
So I've always seen your
intuitive side comes back
when you're out on these
long trips of surrender.
So these are things
that I feel have really
given my career a deep three
dimensional angle that actually
didn't exist before I
started doing these trips.
So that's why I thought it would
be an interesting thing for you
to consider.
I'm going to wrap
up with this idea
that if you're thinking of doing
this, a couple of sample years
that I created for you.
This was the last
about sabbatical, which
is very special in many ways.
We went from Europe to India
by road for three months,
in pretty harsh conditions
like sleeping on train
stations and all of that.
So very intuitively
deciding where
to go when and how to do next.
And then we spent six
months in an ashram in India
doing yoga and meditation.
And then we came back and
lived in an artist retreat
in Portugal.
All of this, surprisingly
enough, like it costs
so less, because you are
in ashram in India-- I
mean, you're talking
like $300 a month
for two people sort of a thing.
Your costs are so
low, and yet I guess
your experiences are very,
very interesting and deep.
The thing that I keep hearing
is that what if you have kids,
you can't do it.
You're going to do it in
a couple of years now.
And what we've seen
is that with kids you
just need a solid routine.
And you can reconstruct
that routine anywhere.
So again in the same
principle, what we've seen
is people do, they spend
four months in an orphanage
in Cambodia, spend four months
in Spain learning something,
spent four months
in an [INAUDIBLE].
You can just reconstruct
that routine anywhere.
And we kind of
plan to do that now
that we have two kids each time.
So very possible
in every scenario.
And you'll benefit a lot
I guess is the message.
Very counterintuitively
you do benefit a lot.
And we kind of
experience some models.
And I'm kind of in this idea
now that the first time you
take this leap of faith,
first it's very hard.
Like the first time I
took it, I was like,
will I be broke and
destitute for all my life?
And I used to think
that, how did I
become this American who was
taking a year to find himself?
Like I was this guy
from India who--
when we were
growing up in India,
we would always
have this concept
of this American backpacker
who took a year to find himself
sort of a thing.
And we'd be like, that's
not a life at all.
We just have to get
a job and stay to it.
When I took the
first sabbatical,
I was just thinking
that this just isn't me.
I was very nervous.
I was like, I don't want to
be this American hippie who
was finding himself.
And I was always kind
of thinking about that.
Anyway, the point being that
it's possible for everyone.
And then when I came back
from the first sabbatical,
it's like you're a little
bit in the crossroads.
You don't come back with
this great sense of centered.
I came back with being like
oh, I love this novel thing.
I love my career thing.
I love this yoga stuff.
What should I do?
And I've seen that.
What I've seen with my
progressive sabbaticals
is that I have no longer left--
like that conflict has just
gone away.
You just start to view life as
just this one interconnected
stream.
I'm going to take up a job
now, going to give it my best.
And then after a
couple of years,
I might take time-- if
that feeling arises,
I'm going to take
the time to write
and I'm going to write
the next novel or whatever
and do something.
And then once that's done,
I'm going to look for a job.
You just start to feel like life
is just one continuous stream
of growth and learning.
And it doesn't
really matter which
vector you're learning
from, all of it
is making you wider
and broader and deeper.
And that's fine.
And I think that's kind
of like a beautiful thing.
It just gives you a
lot of flow with life
without hanging on
to that you need
this thing to grow
this particular job,
this particular role.
And I've seen that
start to happen a lot,
that everything feels like
one interconnected stream.
So I guess that's
the conclusion of it.
I wanted to end with something
very different, which
is whenever I'm nowadays
making tough decisions,
I borrow a lot from
storytelling-- this whole idea
in a good story, the hero always
leaves the known world behind
to enter an unknown world.
So think of "The
Alchemist," "Moby Dick."
Any good story you'll
always have the hero
leave the known world behind,
enter the unknown world,
choosing this very
lofty, unattainable goal
which can't be articulated
almost sometimes.
Or it can be
articulated, but there's
chasing somebody, lofty
unattainable goal.
And even if they
slip and stumble,
you always think that the
story's really successful
because the character has
transformed in the process.
So if I think of
all my novels, they
follow the same
construct of the hero
has left the known world,
gone into the unknown world,
faced conflict after conflict.
It makes the story
really interesting.
And then I started
to play around
with like life is like that.
If you are leaving the
known world behind and going
into the unknown world, there
is no guarantee of success.
Most likely you will face that
death, rebirth kind of moment
in which all is lost.
But it's a damn
interesting story.
So I think life is a
little bit like that.
Leave the known world behind
and hopefully it will come out.
And if it doesn't, it's
a great story anyway.
So with that, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SACHIT EGAN: Thanks
for that, Karan.
KARAN BAJAJ: Thank you.
SACHIT EGAN: Let's
begin with this.
You've said you do so
much work with encouraging
aspiring authors to get started.
You've said that writing a
book is almost like life.
Why is that?
KARAN BAJAJ: Writing
a book is like life--
so I think every book
that I at least write
is constructed on two pillars,
entertainment and meaning.
And if I crack those two,
then I know that I've
cracked a great story.
If I'm very clear on, if
I'm able to articulate what
is that meaning in this novel--
so in this novel, for example,
the meaning comes from what
is enlightenment, what is
the nature of human suffering.
Those are the meaning questions.
But if I write only
meaning, then I'll
write some PhD thesis
on the nature of life
that nobody wants to write.
Then I balance it out with,
what is the entertainment here.
And the entertainment
for me in this book
was that every
inner question has
to be reflected in a
dramatic external journey.
So going from these surreal
night markets to hidden ashrams
to caves high in the Himalayas.
It's a very page
turning adventure.
And if I crack those
two, then I know
that I've got a novel
that I can construct.
So in a sense I feel like life
is a little bit like that.
It's a constant
quest for meaning.
The way to answer that quest for
meaning is not to be cerebral,
but to thrust yourself
into the action.
And my guess is that combination
of entertainment and meaning
makes for a good
story and a good life.
If you stand on only one
foundation, it wobbles.
The story wobbles,
and life wobbles
if you're asking too many
meaningful questions,
not doing enough to act on that.
So yes.
SACHIT EGAN: For sure.
And I've seen online,
you give authors--
aspiring authors--
ideas about how
to find the entertainment and
the meaning in their stories.
Can you talk a little
bit about how you advise
authors to go about that?
KARAN BAJAJ: Oh, great question.
Thank you for asking that.
So for entertainment, I always
say, think of a secret world
that you have some access to
or a deep interest that nobody
has access to.
Like you guys are in a perfect
place right now, right?
Silicon Valley's
so much in culture.
It's not a secret world for
you, but it's a secret world
for the rest of the world.
If you're constructing
a story based
on the inner workings of
a secret society-- which
in this case is Google,
Silicon Valley-- that's
very interesting.
That's really good
entertainment.
So the secret world is
my kind of like theory
for entertainment.
It's hard to pick.
Like in this story for
example, the secret world
is like these hidden
ashrams in India
that at least is interesting
to a subsection of society.
So that's my
entertainment philosophy.
And then meaning of all this
is, what is the deepest question
that you've struggled with.
It could be the death
of a relationship
or it could be finding meaning.
What is the deepest,
most personal question
you're struggling with?
For the most part, if
you kind of explore that,
you will find a lot of
connect with a lot of people
because the human condition
is very, very similar.
SACHIT EGAN: Fair enough.
Something else on this point.
You mentioned you said
live an interesting life.
This is a way you
collect experiences.
You were just
talking about this.
Push yourself.
Go out into the world.
Make things difficult.
Mix things up.
It gives you these
collective experiences
that you can then use
to tell this narrative.
At the same time, you also
mentioned at some point in life
you don't need the 15th
cathedral in Germany,
that experience has almost
become a little cheaper.
Can you talk about
that conflict?
KARAN BAJAJ: Yeah, absolutely.
So in the "Yoga
Sutras of Patanjali,"
which is like a Bible
of yoga in a way,
there's this beautiful idea
that life is a little bit
like the journey of-- it's
like the flight of an eagle.
So an eagle spreads its wings
high and enjoys flight fully.
Grows, enjoys-- and
kind of the human life
is like that, that there is
a time in which you spread
your wings unboundedly and
experience everything that you
can in flight.
But then to complete
the journey,
you have to kind of bring
the wings down and complete
the journey.
I feel a little bit like life
is over a series of lifetimes,
if you believe in that,
or even in this life,
it's a little bit
like you have a period
in which you are experiencing.
And then you'll reach a
little bit of a disenchantment
with the world, if you will.
And then you have to go inner
to complete the journey almost.
SACHIT EGAN: Are
those periods, I
guess, where your reach
that disenchantment,
are those the hiccups on that
trajectory that you talk about?
Are they a necessary part
of the creative process?
KARAN BAJAJ: Yeah, I think so.
Because I think for me
at least, what happened
was that when I was
doing these sabbaticals,
the first one was very external.
Like I was traveling
to all the spaces.
The second one
was also external,
and I started to feel
like a bit of emptiness
through that whole
process of like,
I really don't want to
see the Colosseum in Rome.
It's just not
interesting at all.
I don't want to
see this cathedral.
And I think there's a little
bit of this bump period.
And then that's why
the last sabbatical
has been so internal,
like six months in one
small little ashram in
the middle of nowhere,
and then an [INAUDIBLE].
It was very internal.
Plus it's happened like that.
SACHIT EGAN: I'm wondering, I
find this analogy of the eagle
spreading its wings and
then coming to a place
where it starts to close,
I find it very relevant.
But perhaps to folks who may
not have a similar experience
of what it's like to close those
wings of feel that calling,
how would you
quantify that moment,
or could you describe that?
KARAN BAJAJ: I think
you know, right?
Like you feel a little
bit of the disenchantment
with your setup, as you will.
I think all the
physical signs start
to feel that you-- for
me, those physical signs
were very intense.
I wouldn't enjoy traveling.
I would be with
friends and then people
would talk about, I don't
know, like this dinner
and that restaurant.
And it just felt very empty.
I felt very disconnected
with the world around me.
And I knew that there was
some stronger, inner calling.
That's the first
thing that prompted
me to get really serious
about my meditation and all
that stuff.
SACHIT EGAN: Let's talk
about dharma again.
It's a beautiful concept.
Can you elaborate
on dharma and how
it might apply to Googlers
or people in Silicon Valley?
KARAN BAJAJ: Yeah, absolutely.
So the idea of dharma
really is that, like I said,
every being has a thrust.
Like the trees [INAUDIBLE]
to grow and bear fruit.
And the same way, you as a human
have a little bit of a thrust.
Like you might be pulled
more towards business,
and that's kind of your thrust.
And then even if you start doing
yoga and meditation and all
that stuff, that
doesn't go away.
And it's just like
what they say,
before enlightenment,
chop wood, carry water.
After enlightenment,
So it's really
the dharma doesn't
change, your way of acting
in that environment changes.
And I think what I've
seen in the US is
that people want
to go from point A
to point B very quickly.
They are like lawyers, they
go to a few yoga classes,
and then they want to
become yoga teachers.
The concept of dharma would
be that if you are a lawyer
and you are thriving
in it, don't
wear the robes of the monk
before you become a monk.
Like kind of keep
wearing your robes
and do it in a purified
way, the action.
That's more in line
with the thrust,
and that's what the world needs.
And that's what you will
act in accordance with.
So that's beautiful.
So if your thrust is to be an
engineer, that's beautiful.
Go take all this time
off and come back,
and you'll still be an engineer.
You won't become a yoga
teacher at the end of it.
You will just be
a more, I guess,
silent engineer, more
silent in your mind
while still doing
the same activity.
SACHIT EGAN: For sure.
I think it's worth mentioning at
this point is one way the book,
"The Yoga of Max's
Discontent," or "The Seeker,"
has been described as a
modern day "Siddhartha."
And probably many
in the room knows
"Siddhartha" by Hermann Hesse
is just a very foundational
spiritual novel for the West.
And it's that
comparison that actually
convinced me to read the book.
"Siddhartha," not
to give anything
away-- spoiler
alert-- it kind of
describes life as being stages.
That you might begin
chop wood, carry water,
but then tomorrow
you're a business man.
And then tomorrow you're
a yogi, an ascetic living
somewhere else--
big, drastic changes
over the course of a life.
And I guess your vision with
dharma is a little different.
KARAN BAJAJ: A
little bit, because I
think "Siddhartha" is also
a little bit of a metaphor
for multiple lives.
And obviously since multiple
lives is a very metaphysical
concept, that can take
away from storytelling,
because people have to
believe in something.
So obviously he
kind of charts out
the whole of human
life in one book.
I think dharma would say that
there is gradual movement.
So you know, if
you're an engineer
and you go into
the spiritual life,
you will still be an
engineer with a silent mind.
And then slowly, maybe
slowly, slowly, slowly, you
will become the
meditation like teacher.
But you don't have to like--
life is a slow unfolding
and not as dramatic.
I have to go from
becoming this to-- it's
not always a
journey of becoming.
It's a slow journey
of unfolding.
SACHIT EGAN: Something
that I was curious about
is the main character in
your latest book is Max.
And Max starts in New
York, and he goes to India,
ends up in India, Himalayas.
You started Himalayas,
go to New York,
go to Himalayas, but then
now back to New York.
Why the difference?
It seems like you and Max
have a different path.
KARAN BAJAJ: Yeah, and it
really happened, little bit
almost consciously that in
this particular book also,
I really wanted to eliminate all
sense of authorship completely.
I really wanted the story
to take on its own--
when you read the book,
I just wanted the person
to be transported into
effective dream in which they
can sense no presence
of an author at all.
And really kind of his
journey became his own
and became more and more
leave the world behind.
And my journey is not that.
SACHIT EGAN: Sure, OK.
Could you maybe
talk a little bit
about how when you realized
that that journey was different,
that the people who were at this
ashram, some of them wanted,
I guess, enlightenment
in this life,
and you decided that's a
different path for you?
KARAN BAJAJ: Yeah.
So when I was living in
this ashram for six months,
during the time that I
left, I felt this time
that there's a very strong
likelihood that my girlfriend--
who is my wife now.
At that point I talked
to her about that,
that there's a strong likelihood
that I might never come back.
I grew up in the Indian
tradition in which
people became ascetics.
And it was kind of like you
did watch lawyers, doctors,
engineers become ascetics
up in the Himalayas,
become these cave
dwelling yogis.
And I was feeling
that I would become--
I was comfortable with
this idea that at the end
of this sabbatical,
I would never
want to come back and become
a cave dweller in some form.
And during the course
of living in the ashram,
this idea of dharma
became very clear to me
because I was not in my element.
I was in the ashram.
I was enjoying myself.
I could see how I
was transforming.
I was deepening in my yoga
and meditation practice.
But I always knew that I
was kind of out of sorts.
And on the other
hand, I started to see
people who were out of
sorts before in their world
becoming completely in line,
in rhythm in the ashram.
It was very interesting
to see that I felt out
of sorts despite learning
a lot, and people suddenly
felt that they were
completely in rhythm
and this is what they
were meant to be.
And there are so many people who
just lived in ashram forever.
And I just knew that it
was just not my thrust.
SACHIT EGAN: Sure.
Thanks for sharing that.
Something I find interesting
about the message
that you share now
is it seems like you
postulate that you can't
have it all, at some levels.
What I mean by that is, a lot
of self-help books or even
spiritual books,
they suggest that you
don't have to pick between
spirituality and your thrust
and the material world.
That if you take
that sabbatical,
you take that year every
three to four years,
you not only become a better
yogi, a better author, you also
become a better
business, a better CEO.
And I've always been
skeptical of that.
It feels like you kind of have
to pick what your life is about
and forget about
the consequences.
But you think you
could have both?
KARAN BAJAJ: Yeah.
I think you can have both.
But I think it's fine if
you slip down one path.
I think the biggest
difference is
that I think the Western
culture is all about becoming.
Go from point A to point B. Go
from lawyer to yoga teacher,
from business profession
to self-help coach.
People are always becoming.
And I guess my model is
more like, it has to unfold.
Let it unpeel and unfold.
Let me just keep
purifying where I am.
And slowly and
slowly and slowly--
For example, in this classic
example of my own career,
when I was at Procter &
Gamble, I was very linear.
I was working in my
brand management job.
If I think of in the
last five, seven years,
as my art has deepened, as
I've really become serious
about writing and
become more and more,
at least in my opinion,
more purer to the art form,
my career has transformed.
Now I'm running a
media company in India,
which is like a perfect balance
of business and creativity.
My whole job there is
to commission shows.
And that requires me
to be very intuitive
and [INAUDIBLE]
oriented on what's
going to be in zeitgeist.
In P&G, that's not your job.
And then BCG, definitely it
was a very analytical job.
So what I've seen is that life
slowly unpeels and unfolds,
versus me there being like OK,
I'm going to quit everything
and I'm going to
become [INAUDIBLE].
And I wasn't ready yet.
So I think slow unfolding.
SACHIT EGAN: Thank you.
To pivot, something
that we're fortunate
here as Googlers to
have is we occasionally
have authors like yourself
who come in and are
very encouraging of
other aspiring authors.
A few weeks ago we had Anna
Quindlen actually sitting here
in this chair in this room.
And one of the questions that
was posed from an audience
member was, this Googler,
she wanted to be an author.
And she took two years
off, somehow managed
to get a sabbatical,
rented a cabin,
wanted to do the
Walden thing and really
kind of focus on the writing.
And it didn't work out.
She mentioned that
she got distracted
and it was very hard
to just kind of dive
into the creative process
sort of on demand.
And yet you'll jump for six
months here, take a year there,
and you find that
it's easy to commit
to a certain number
of words per day.
Can you talk about--
KARAN BAJAJ: Yeah, I think
the biggest difference is
that because my
vision is not to make
money from my writing, become
a full-time writer-- if it
happens, great, but
that's not my vision
I guess-- I am writing only
when I can't help but write.
So it's almost like
I am treating life
as a ground to gain experience.
And then when the well fills
up and reaches a point where
I just can't help but write--
And so for example,
on this third novel,
I quit my job six weeks before
my second baby was born.
And it was the most
irrational thing, right?
Why can't you wait six weeks
and get your company's insurance
to have your kid being born?
It's silly to
self-destruct like that.
But I reach a point
where I'm like,
I can't help but
start writing today.
And I just wait for
that point to happen.
And now that's what I'm seeing.
The beautiful thing
now is that I'm
starting to see that
it's all one stream view.
In a way like it's OK
if I have to quit a job
six weeks before my
baby's born, because I
want to write because I'm
going to learn something
through that writing.
And then I'll come back
and find some other job.
It will all work out eventually.
But I think the difference is
that when people want to write,
when they go to write, I
don't know if their well is
full enough to overflow.
And I feel like you should use
life to overflow your well,
and then like you can't
help but get the story down.
SACHIT EGAN: I see.
If we return to the example
of you having a second child
on the way in six weeks, I
gather that a lot of folks
will feel very conflicted to
be the responsible parent,
or to kind of, in a way, pursue
this dream or this calling--
feelings of guilt,
perhaps, which is a very
self-defeating sort of feeling.
How would you advise
people to get over that,
or would you advise
people to get over that?
KARAN BAJAJ: I would
say as you keep
doing more and more such stuff,
the conclusion that you draw
is that as long as you are
honestly choosing growth
as a human being, it
always kind of works out.
But you just have to
get-- like somewhere
that mindset has to break
that I'm leaving my job
and I'm not doing the
right thing for my baby.
I'm like, I'm leaving this
job to work very, very
intensely on a different job,
which is to write this novel.
And then I'm going to leave
that job to work very intensely,
or to work full honesty
on my media company role.
And you kind of start to see
that everything is like, as
long as your
intentions are honest
and you are-- you don't see
that demarcation that much.
My wife was saying,
are you crazy?
Sort of a thing like, why
can't you wait for six weeks?
And I'm like, no, this
is the time to write.
I'm going to do it.
And hopefully it will all work.
It does.
SACHIT EGAN: For sure.
I think one thing you
said really resonates.
You talk about if your
intentions are pure.
And I think that's profound.
Here in Silicon Valley-- you
can relate to this-- everything
is analyzed.
Everything is overanalyzed.
For every point there
is a counterpoint.
For every one person
who thinks, hey
you're doing great by growing
as a human, nine people
will say you're
being irresponsible.
How do you find that
self-assuredness to know, hey,
I trust my intentions?
KARAN BAJAJ: The first
time it's hardest.
Second time, not so hard.
Third time-- by the
fifth time, you're like,
my life is my own model.
There's no model left anymore.
So I think the first
time-- especially
we all have our own concerns.
Like my mom would be
like, are you depressed?
Why are you leaving
your job to travel?
Is something wrong in
your-- like you know,
I was telling you should
have been married by now.
There's always some
external pressure.
But now nobody even
questions anything.
They're just like, he's
on his own mad path.
By now, there's no sense of
waiting for anybody's judgment
left anymore.
So I think the first
time is the hardest.
So you keep doing it.
And then by the fifth
time, it's like, there's
nobody to explain to anymore.
SACHIT EGAN: Very cool.
Appreciate it.
I'd love to turn it over
to you guys as well.
Angela, if you don't mind
being the mic person.
Just raise your hand.
AUDIENCE: Are there any
practical or logistical things
that you've had to give up
to prepare for your next
sabbatical?
Like a small one
might be like, I'm
not going to own a pet because
then the logistics of leaving
are going to be too hard,
or something more serious.
KARAN BAJAJ: It's such
a beautiful question
because I do want to
[INAUDIBLE] like so.
So why I think it's a
very interesting question
is because I think
my wife and have I
talked a little bit
about that, which
is to just jump into
life fully and not think
about almost the next step.
So for example we're moving
to India now on October 2
to take on this role.
We have a five-month-old
and a two-year-old
and all that stuff.
And we have a pet which we're
leaving with my wife's parents.
It's a little heart wrenching.
But would I have not had
the pet because of that?
No.
But it's almost like we're
just diving in and saying
yes, yes, yes, and not thinking
too much about-- it always
has a way of working out.
But it's to your point.
It's a very great point.
But there's some
things that I do.
I don't buy a house ever.
That's just a philosophy.
At this age, everybody
in India has five houses.
But I don't know.
People invest in this
land and that property.
I don't invest in anything
which can weigh me down at all.
So there's some
choices that I make.
But for the most part, we're
diving into the experience
of being.
So we decided to have
a-- for example, anybody
would question why go to Mumbai
with a five-month-old American
kid who's going to
be like obviously
assaulted from the
senses completely
and is going to have obviously
have some digestion problems.
But we're just like,
let's just dive in
and see what it takes you.
Perhaps we should think
more, but we don't.
AUDIENCE: How do you bring your
partner or girlfriend or wife
at the time to join you
in those sabbaticals?
Or do you go on your own?
KARAN BAJAJ: No, the
first two were because I
was single for the most part.
So I went on my own.
But the next one, like we
were in a relationship.
And I think what happens is once
you start building the muscle--
the first one, when you
do it even on your own,
it's difficult. It's not as
hunky dory as I make it here.
I guess you are very conflicted.
You do it.
And even when you're doing
it, I had those moments
when I was like, how
did I become a hippie?
I was supposed to
be this and that.
So you go through those
self-doubts and stuff.
The next one is you
build the muscle.
Then the same thing what
happens is with your partner.
It's harder to do,
because you have
to have two jobs that
have to be planned
and sabbaticals and stuff.
But eventually you do
that, and you kind of
build the muscle for next time.
And you do it for the kids.
So I think what happens is that
progressively, the journey gets
easier.
You just keep
building the muscle.
So my recommendation on that is
to try a month off rather than
just jump into a year.
Do something which builds
your guys [INAUDIBLE].
And then slowly that one
month will become three.
And then the next you both will
be aligned to take the plunge.
You can you keep building
the muscle, and yeah-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: I have a follow
on to that question.
Can you talk about the pros and
cons of doing a sabbatical solo
versus with your partner?
KARAN BAJAJ: For me they were
mostly pros, this time over.
But there was a lot of merit
that I was doing it on my own
also.
I don't know if there is
a straight answer to-- I
don't know if it's a choice.
If you have a partner,
would you guys
be comfortable taking a year
off away from each other?
Like for me, we never even
contemplated that question
and we just did it
together, if you will.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
was just wondering
is it-- I personally,
I can see it both ways.
I can see it being
very fulfilling
going by yourself, if you have
that trust with a partner,
leaving the partner behind
if it doesn't work for them.
But I was curious, was
one experience better
than the other?
KARAN BAJAJ: Very
different experiences.
I think the difference though
is that you grow so much
in that year, grow so much.
And it's very apparent,
but so many aspects of you
change that when
you come back, it'll
be a little hard if
the other person hasn't
gone through the same
experience with you.
So I won't have worried
too much about the year.
But after spending six
months in an ashram,
writing a novel in the
Portuguese artist retreat,
going from Europe
to India by road,
through that whole experience,
a very different form of you
emerges.
And then if that other person
hasn't had that experience,
it's a very big, I
would say, disconnect.
I don't think our relationship
would have survived
if I'd just done it on my own.
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering if you could
talk a little bit about
your writing process, things
like same kind of block
of time during each day.
Do you outline the
whole thing first?
Do you write very
quick first drafts
and then edit over and
over and over again?
KARAN BAJAJ: The writing
process, for me, it
is a good combination of
tight and slack, almost
like my life in
some ways that I'm
very goal driven
and disciplined,
and then I completely let
loose when the goal driven
and discipline period-- I'm
kind of a bit of a maniac.
I know that I'm going to write
Monday, Tuesday and Thursday,
one hour each after work, or 1
and 1/2 hours each after work,
and produce 400 words.
So it's almost very
mathematical to a science.
And then I like one weekend,
either Saturday or Sunday,
and I'll write a thousand words.
If you do that, for
example, in six months
you'll complete a whole novel.
That's 80,000 words.
If you're continuously showing
up and doing that-- and I'm
very mathematical
almost about it.
So Monday, Tuesday,
Thursday, so that
allows me the slack to play
on Wednesday and Friday.
It allows me to spend one
full weekend with my kids.
But the second weekend, we call
a babysitter and for five hours
I'm working on my
book or whatever.
And then I complete the novel.
But what I notice then is that
the work is very workman like
and is not magical.
And then the sabbatical
kind of somehow
shows up somewhere in
the middle of that,
and that's when the work
starts to-- I slacken a lot,
and then the work
becomes magical.
So I think of this novel, I
had written two drafts before I
even went on the year off.
And those drafts
were very linear
and like a predictable
story, very outline driven.
And then in the sabbatical, I
didn't write for the first nine
months.
As I said, I was in Europe
to India, then in the ashram.
Then I wrote in
this Portuguese--
I completed the novel
in this artist retreat.
And what I've written in that
period is very transcendental.
I can't even
recognize it anymore.
If you asked me
to write it again,
I would never be
able to write it.
It just took on
its own-- it came
from a place of deep silence.
No goals because in this
artist retreat, I was not like,
I'm going to clock
these number of words.
I was just being very
inspired in writing.
So it's a combination of
very much a lot of discipline
and then a lot of free slack.
And that combination I
think really cracks it.
If it was like leaning
too much in one direction,
I would not get the work done,
like in this free flow thing.
Or I would be so workman like
that it doesn't inspire me
at all.
SACHIT EGAN: One quick
follow up to that.
You talked about
this briefly before.
To me, creativity
feels hard to box.
If I set out for
Monday, Tuesday,
Thursday to write 100,
200, 300, 400 words,
it's hard to predict,
will the idea
for the rest of this
chapter come to me now?
How do you take breaks?
How you stop for the day?
Do you just write down the
rest of your ideas quickly?
What do you do?
KARAN BAJAJ: No, I just
keep-- like I almost
feel like it's my duty
to show up in this period
and work for 1 and 1/2 hours.
And typically that
means producing 300,
400 words is what I've noticed.
So I'm almost like
very-- then obviously
some days when it
doesn't come at all.
But I'm more committed to
the idea of let me show up
and do that, and then
maybe delete it later.
Very comfortable with this idea,
to your question, first drafts
and stuff.
But I think it's
very important for me
to show up and not be like,
I'm not feeling inspired today.
SACHIT EGAN: I guess what I
mean is let's say you do show up
and you feel super inspired.
And hour and a half passes and
you just feel like, keep going.
How do you contain--
KARAN BAJAJ: No,
actually, if that happens,
then I'm really
inspired to keep going.
Then I don't stop myself.
The opposite I do.
But once you have a
couple of kids and stuff
and you've done a full time
job and you come back at home,
it's very hard to
feel that inspired
to just keep plugging
away after-- I
start to swim a little.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
you have two kids.
So when you would do
those sabbaticals,
did you bring them with you?
KARAN BAJAJ: Because we had
it after the last sabbatical.
But we tried out an experiment
of taking six weeks off
in Costa Rica recently, with the
kids, to see how it would work.
And it worked very well.
The whole point was that
if you can construct-- kids
are like pets in a way.
If you construct a
routine for them,
if you just take that routine--
if you leave it unstructured,
then obviously
they won't thrive.
But if you go to
Costa Rica you're
creating a similar routine
that you drop them in--
so it's a small preparation.
Like to look for
daycares in Costa Rica
and do exactly the same routine.
The goal, you drop them to a
daycare and you do your work
and you pick them up.
So it's very--
AUDIENCE: Was there in school?
I'm not sure how that--
KARAN BAJAJ: Yeah, that's true.
But I have friends
who are doing it now,
they just shift to
a-- so my friend
just did it with kids
who are 13, 11, and 10.
And they basically shifted
from the US to Spain,
and shifted them for
one year in that school.
And apparently the
kids loved it so
much they didn't want to leave.
And then they did
that three years ago,
and they're doing it again.
They're doing one more year
at a very funny stage, 17,
when they're just about, I
guess, go to [INAUDIBLE].
So they're doing it at
17, 15, and 14 now, again.
So they just constructed
like the exact life
in a different place.
AUDIENCE: How did
you decide what
you want in your sabbatical?
Did you preplan that
you want to spend
three months at this place and
three months at that place?
KARAN BAJAJ: It's a very
good question actually.
What I felt is that anchored
events are very good.
So for us, we knew that the
anchor event was yoga teachers
training in India in November.
But we didn't know what we would
do between August and November.
So it was good to have the
sense that we would reach India,
but how we would reach
India, what would happen
in those three months-- like
we just had this idea that we
would take the cheapest
mode of transport and living
everywhere.
And that was the
whole construct.
So that meant never having a
car, never taking a flight,
just being on the road or
ferries or all that stuff,
and just kept drifting along
and reach India eventually,
through China and all
this like random places
and just keep drifting,
drifting, drifting
until we reached.
But then it was good to have
the anchor that we would
do yoga teachers training.
Then there was
another anchor that we
would do the Camino
de Santiago, which is
this wonderful hike in Spain.
And there was another
anchor that we
would do it in five months
time around March, April.
That's very good
timing to do it.
So that was the
other anchor event.
So there are anchor
events, but then there's
a lot of free flow.
AUDIENCE: Are there any day to
day or week to week practices
that you do to help sort of
align with this lifestyle
while you're unfolding versus
trying to become something?
KARAN BAJAJ: Like the usual.
I do try to meditate.
Definitely I meditate in the
night before I hit to bed.
The morning is
very unpredictable
with two young kids,
can be unpredictable.
But I do definitely meditate.
I think there are
three things, really,
to answer that question,
like meditation, creation.
I think creation always
keeps you honest.
So even if I'm not
working on a novel,
I'm blogging and doing my-- I
just do my five minute YouTube
videos.
I think creation
has a beautiful way
of synthesizing your thoughts.
When you write a blog post, you
are forced to almost synthesize
your thoughts.
And I have a good audience
who reads the blogs.
I get a lot of feedback to them.
So I think it's meditation,
creation, and then hiking,
like kind of a tough
hike or something.
Basically the idea
is that you're
doing an activity that
completely breaks down
your world and transports you
to a different world on a more
regular basis.
So same with a tough
hike, you just completely
forget yourself
when you're hiking.
So I think those are the
three kind of activities.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
This is a little offbeat.
It's related to the book.
So you talk about how
doing meditation sort of
brings you more
realizations and awareness,
and answers a lot of
questions that you have.
So I wanted to know,
what kind of meditation
did you start off with?
And even when you start
off with something,
your thought is a
certain practice.
So you start practicing it.
And do you just
continue doing that,
and do these realizations
start anew in the process?
KARAN BAJAJ: Excellent question.
I think the pyramid of the
meditation experience, which
I found worked and has worked
obviously in the Buddhist
scripture as well is that
you start with what they call
morality, which is a basic
level of love for yourself
and love for others.
That means changing
your diet to be
like less agitating,
less caffeine,
less alcohol, all
that kind of stuff.
You kind of lay the
foundation of that.
Then you go over to
concentration based meditation
where you use a
form as a surrogate
to build that ability of the
mind to go from scattered
to one pointed.
And then the concentration based
meditation evolves by itself
to the awareness,
mindfulness states
where there is no form at all.
You are comfortable with
formlessness, if you will.
But what I've seen
is that they just
happen on their own accord.
I didn't have this
construct in the beginning.
Later when I started to
see why-- in the beginning,
I was very form based.
I would meditate on an image,
use my breadth, use a mantra.
I had a very form based
practice to build concentration.
And then the forms started
to disappear on their own.
I no longer needed forms.
But I didn't make this
choice that OK, now I've
achieved some greatness in
form, I'll go to formless.
But I think that's
what I've noticed
is the pattern that happened
is that the moment I
became more one pointed, the
forms disappeared on their own.
AUDIENCE: How much
did you meditate?
KARAN BAJAJ: In the beginning
I was very disciplined.
So in the beginning I was
very, very disciplined
about putting 30 minutes in
the morning and 30 minutes
in the night every day.
And in the beginning
I actually started
to construct a similar
thing that I'll
do Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday,
Thursday, not Friday.
But I started to see the
benefits of it very quickly.
And so I did it
every day almost.
And so I almost did
that for a year or two
before taking the sabbatical
to kind of deep dive
into things and stuff.
I would highly recommend, if
you haven't done it already,
Vipassana is a beautiful--
which everybody should do.
It's a ten day silent
meditation retreat.
It's beautiful because
it's fully funded, that you
don't pay for anything.
You're going to a place
where the lodging is free,
the food is free.
And you are given this very
rigorous instruction from 4:00
in the morning till
10:00 in the night,
and you don't speak at all
for nine out of those 10 days.
The beauty of
everything being paid
for is that you don't complain
and mourn because you truly
approach that whole
experience like a monk
with a begging bowl, because
you're like somebody's
just paying for me to do this.
I can't just sit
here and complain
about how difficult it is.
You just surrender
to it completely.
I would highly recommend that.
There are many
centers all around
and they're very
consistent everywhere.
They do the same practice.
It's a beautiful way
to start meditating.
That's also very
concentration based approach.
AUDIENCE: Very, provoking.
So I can see why blood pressure
going up in your speech,
thinking if I should
take a sabbatical or not.
So you mentioned about the
word [INAUDIBLE] a few times.
They were in your
sabbatical, [INAUDIBLE]
out in that one year.
But when you go back,
we see your graph
showing your career
progression to the right,
going from manager
to director and being
a CEO, which for me is
a sign that you have
that ambition of progression,
getting rewarded accordingly,
making more money probably.
So I wonder if,
before everything
started, if you had some
financial goals in your mind.
So at a certain age, I
want to be at this point,
and if that changed at all,
or if you still have it?
KARAN BAJAJ: Great question,
because I can't even believe
how much it's transformed.
To give you an example,
when my wife and I climbed
Kilimanjaro-- that was
like about five years ago,
four years ago.
And she mentions that now.
She was girlfriend
then obviously.
I had this red diary in which
I was noting down my plans,
because I was so
inspired in Kilimanjaro,
I was just like noting
down how I would,
what I would do two years from
now, three years from now,
by age this, this, this.
Now I look at it,
I mean, nothing.
No goals are left at all.
Nothing is left.
I mean, till one month
ago, we didn't even
know that I would take
up a job in Mumbai.
It came cup.
I was looking at
a job in Mumbai,
and at the same time in
New York, in Connecticut.
And it just was like,
well this is great,
and we just jumped into--
like I have no idea where
this role takes me.
It's completely
changed completely now.
Now it's really
truly that living
in the moment sort of a thing.
Its just like, do your
best in the moment.
But it's changed dramatically.
Through all of this, I think
the goallessness has become
very sound, because I
think some day you realize
that if your intentions
are right, it all comes,
all of these things come.
And you changed so
much in the journey
that you have lost--
like I know that you're
going to change so much
going to Mumbai as a family
and working in this
thing, I'm going
to change so much that I can
have no static goals at all.
What I want six months
to one year from now
is going to be very different
than what I want now.
So that has disappeared
a lot, yeah.
SACHIT EGAN: Any other questions
in the audience, maybe one
more, time for one more?
If not, I'll throw
one last one at you.
You exude this positivity.
I guess it's implicit
in the way you
are willing to jump
without a plan,
not worried about
taking the kids
on a sabbatical, which would
freak, I think, a lot of us
out.
I guess I'm curious, is that
an implicit positivity that's
always been there for you?
Have you developed it?
Has it grown?
KARAN BAJAJ: No,
exactly like that.
Think of this obviously,
like not negative.
I was reasonably a positive guy.
But I was a regular worrier.
You come from an Indian
family, most of us come
from very ethnic background.
Obviously we're here, so
we've come from people who
are very kind of regimented.
You come from those
kind of families,
you're obviously very
worried about life.
You want it to be a certain way.
And I remember at
age 31 reaching
a point when I'd just come
back from my first sabbatical.
And at age 31, I
didn't have money.
I was single.
The recession hit, so I was
very close to losing my job.
And I was like, how
did this happen?
At age 31 I was supposed
to be like this Indian guy,
not this random loser like--
I don't know.
So the thing is that now I've
started to believe that it all
works out.
As long as your
intentions are pure,
it always has a way of
connecting to each other.
That experience at age 31 led
to a very, very good novel,
because I felt the
depth of despair, which
lead to great art, which
opened the doors to new things,
and then life just took off to
a whole different direction.
So I don't know.
So I've become more
positive in the sense
that now I trust completely
that it's going to work out.
SACHIT EGAN: And
just to piggyback
with one last thing
about that, something
that I've seen you
mention on your website
is on the one hand,
detachment is important
and you have to find
comfort in being alone.
In fact in the book, I think
there's a European seeker who
says that all the
problems in the world
are because man is
unable to sit alone
by himself in a room,
which I really liked.
But you also mentioned
the value of connecting
with other positive people
or like minded people.
That community is
really powerful.
When you are outside that
community, when you're
working in the corporate
world, that positivity
is perhaps less present.
How do you deal with that?
KARAN BAJAJ: It's a
good point, because-- I
mean, it's a good-- when you
are on these sabbaticals,
you actually end
up meeting people.
Like I was just telling you just
before this conversation also,
like in a ten day
silent retreat,
of which nine days you're silent
and not speaking with anybody.
On the 10th day you're
speaking to people.
You actually end
up meeting people
that you feel more
connected to than people
you've known all your lives,
or friends that you've
talked to every day.
Because there's something
about the seeking community,
if you will, who are all kind of
like dabblers on the same path,
asking these questions,
struggling with their answers.
And you feel like that image,
like love and bond for them.
Yoga teachers training, which
again, I recommend everybody
do, the six week,
living in an ashram.
It's like living in college
but completely your people.
They're all asking
the same things.
And it's very beautiful.
And then when you
come back obviously,
those experiences
are few and far
in between of that
complete connection.
I don't know how I-- I guess I
don't come-- it's OK, you know?
Part of the journey is
silence and aloneness
and learning through
reading and reflection
and your own practice.
And part of the
journey is communal.
You can't wish for it.
I guess the bigger
point is that any time I
start feeling any kind
of a lack in my life,
I know that my meditation
practice is not working.
Because the moment that feelings
of lack start to come-- I
don't have friends,
or I don't have this,
I don't have that-- I know
that the fundamental assumption
of this whole
meditation practice
is that there's a
completeness that exists.
And you have to kind
of like form oneness
with that completeness.
So the moment I'm starting
to think in those thought
patterns, I know that
I'm slipping somewhere
in the meditation.
So I just redouble my meditation
practice I guess is the answer.
SACHIT EGAN: Well
thanks for that.
Karan Bajaj's "The Yoga of Max's
Discontent," available now.
I can't promise you'll
love it as much as I did,
but it's pretty good.
Karan, thanks for being here.
KARAN BAJAJ: It was wonderful.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]